YUFENG GUO: Hi.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And today we're
going to explore how
you can build a solution
with Google Cloud AI
by taking a look at the use case
of using AI in manufacturing
for increased productivity.
Our example comes from
the machining industry.
So let's first talk a bit
about what machining is.
Machining is the
process for cutting
raw materials, such
as metal, wood,
or plastic, into a desired
final shape and size.
Modern machine shops use
computer-controlled precision
machining tools for operations
like cutting, drilling, boring,
milling, and so on.
Machining is an essential part
of the manufacturing industry.
Historically, a major challenge
of the machining industry
is the time-consuming
task of cost estimation.
For instance, when
a machine shop
takes an order for
building parts like these,
it needs to determine the
individual cuts and holes that
need to be made for
each individual part
by carefully reading
the blueprint provided
by the customer.
This manual process
requires machining experts
who are dedicated to the cost
estimation process, which
can act as a bottleneck for
the productivity of the machine
shop as a whole.
A company called Kabuku
in Japan has launched
a new solution
for this challenge
by handling the data management
of their machining process
with AI.
Kabuku is a startup focused on
modernizing the manufacturing
industry with 3D
printing, cloud,
and AI technologies for major
manufacturing customers,
including Toyota,
Honda, and Olympus.
Let's see how Kabuku's
data management tool works.
First, a blueprint is uploaded
to the tool in the web browser,
and a region is
specified for estimation.
Then the user simply presses
the Cost Estimation button.
The tool detects and
highlights every object
that requires processing.
You can see the detected
types of processing steps,
how many there are,
how much each costs,
and the total estimated
costs for the entire part.
The tool also allows users to
add detailed info for each part
or to have experts update any
part that requires minor fixes.
The tool can detect
tens of processing parts
on the design in less than one
second, which significantly
increases the productivity
of cost estimation
by machining experts.
Masahiko Adachi, CEO
of Kabuku, explains
the benefit of this tool.
"If machine shops
can respond quickly
to cost estimation requests
from their customers,
that's a better customer
experience and more business
opportunities.
Additionally, this tool can
act as a central repository
of expert knowledge
for each machine shop.
This allows the shop to
easily share knowledge
with junior staff
members and learners
without any bottlenecks and make
business operations much more
scalable."
Let's learn more
about how Kabuku
built this tool with the
power of Google Cloud AI.
Kabuku's tool was able to
detect the machining operations
from the blueprint.
To achieve this, they used
our AutoML Vision technology
with object detection.
First they collected thousands
of images in preparation
for ML model training, with
different labeled blueprints
for drilling, boring, and
cutting operations on them.
Usually, it would
take a lot of time
to build an object detection
system using their training
data for production use.
You would need to start
with data pre-processing,
and ML model design,
hyperparameter tuning,
evaluation, and
deployment, and would also
need to have resources to
keep the model up to date.
And that would require hiring
AI experts and ML engineers.
For faster
time-to-market, Kabuku
chose our AutoML
technology which automates
many steps in the ML lifecycle.
All they had to do was
upload their training images
to AutoML Vision and
press the Train button
to start the automated model
training and development
process.
In half a day, they got
an object detection model
generated by AutoML Vision with
a detailed report of the model
accuracy and various metrics.
Then Kabuku downloaded
the ML model
and used it with
TensorFlow.js, which
allows you to run the object
detection within a web browser.
That's the reason why Kabuku's
machining data management
tool is able to detect tens of
processing parts in just one
second.
Even though you could
build the object detection
model much faster
with AutoML Vision,
that's not the whole story.
One important requirement
for a Kabuku's tool
is the ability to keep
learning from the experts.
The practices and patterns
used in blueprints
are different for each customer
project or machining expert.
So the tool provides a UI for
fixing the misdetected parts
or adding more details.
Based on this
feedback from experts,
the tool reruns the
ML training process
and deploys a better ML model
that captures the practices
and patterns used in each case.
To implement this continuous
ML training process,
Kabuku used Cloud AI
platform pipelines.
This product allows users to
build orchestrated ML pipelines
and manage them from
data pre-processing
and validation all
the way through
to model training,
validation, and deployment.
Instead of asking AI
experts again and again
for a manual rerun of the
whole training process,
everything can be automated
and continuously integrated
just by invoking the pipeline,
making the whole service robust
and production ready.
With AI platform
pipelines, Kabuku
was able to build
a positive feedback
loop between the machining
experts and model training
pipeline, resulting in
ever-better accuracy
of their model and
higher productivity
as the experts keep
using the tool.
This loop of
application and training
is called active learning in ML.
In summary, Kabuku was able to
use the power of Google Cloud
AI for faster time-to-market,
quick object detection,
and create a flexible ML
pipeline for active learning.
What will your AI
journey look like?
Get started today with these
tools from Google Cloud AI.
[MUSIC FADING OUT]